s
chinois lancés vers les eaux
territoriales taïwanaises,
des avions de chasse
dans le détroit de Taïwan.
Les exercices militaires sont
d'une ampleur sans précédent.
la zone économique japonaise.
C'est la réponse chinoise
promise à la visite, plus tôtlo,
la présidente de la Chambre
des représentants américains.
"
n'apportent que chaos et
sosordre lorsqu'ils disent
exprimer leur solidarité avec
un territoire", lance-t-elle.
qu'elle ne fait que défendre
sa souveraineté. Elle considère
Taïwan comme son territoire et
parle même de rééducation
des Taïwanais à venir
après la réunification.
qualifie ces tirs de missiles
balistiques d'irrationnels.
L'île dit surveiller de près
prête à faire la guerre
sans pour autant la chercher.
répètent qu'ils n'ont pas changé
et ils espèrent que Pékin
ne fabriquera pas une crise.
Si les exercices d'une ampleur
jamais vue font craindre
une nouvelle crise dans
le dét
sur l'île, l'inquiétude
ne semble pas avoir grimpé.
Des exercices militaires
chinois, prévus et annoncée e et
se poursuivre jusqu'à dimanche.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Tainan,ududududï.